hi everyone alex gin here so today i'm
going to continue talking about figure
eight speeds
and this time how you can use footwork
to move whilst spinning
if you haven't already seen my previous
video on figure eight spins
then i'll put a link either above or in
the description down below
otherwise let's get into it
[Music]
key point to understand before
introducing footwork is that forward
spin on one side
links in with the backward spin on the
opposite side
and vice versa if for example i was
spinning in a forwards figure eight here
as i let it sweep down in this arc i
stop
and note to myself i started with the
forged figure eight so now this needs to
be backwards figure eight
and then i continue with the backwards
figure eight
and then again when i take it back over
i take it back over the top and pause
and then go back to the forwards figure
eight and the same could be done if i
was going backwards
so if i was going backwards
i take it over the top stop
and now i'm back into a board figuring
stop
sweep back over and now i'm back into a
backwards figure
and when you have this movement where
you feel that you're comfortable
you can then let it just flow from side
to side
you also want to maintain clean flames
so if you can create a visual barrier
either side of you and if you can see
here i've got two lines
here and here if i was spinning i don't
want to let it stray over those lines
like this i want to try and keep
everything nice and tight
so it doesn't go within without outside
of those lines
so then when you're turning it actually
makes things a lot easier
if i show you side on like this
as i take it over to this side you can
see
it still remains within that boundary
same when i go back over to the other
side i'm not letting it drift
either side by doing something like this
or taking it outwards
you just want to make sure that you keep
it within that boundary
whilst you're spinning
the other important point to understand
is where the staff is in relation to me
as a spinner
so if for example i'm spinning here in
this position
to me it feels like i'm spinning front
to back
but if i turn my hips and i face this
direction
it now feels like i'm spinning side to
side
but to you as a viewer it still looks
the same
so the first step to try is getting this
feeling where you've got it spinning
front to back and then rotating your
hips
where it's now side to side but the spin
hasn't really changed it's just my body
that's
moved so here's front to back
and then side to side you can also do
this both directions
you can then turn and this time when
we're
side on take the front leg
back and now we're in this position
which is spinning across your body you
can then
take another step forward and then turn
back square
so we're just moving one foot and
pivoting on the other
so yeah
and if you need to break it down so
stop and continue the figure eight
stop take a step back and then continue
the figure eight
stop you can just pause between those
points
if you need to until you can do it
smoothly
again practice that both directions and
both sides
so you also want to practice stepping
back while spinning across your body
so in this position i'll take a step
back
continue spinning
and just get used to this being able to
step forward and backwards
whilst spinning then go square
and now we can join it up with the other
side
we'll step back step forwards
and then continue the movement through
to the other side as well
and now we're moving from side to side
you know a step
forward backwards
if i'm spinning forwards in this
position and i take my foot back
i can continue the movement this way
towards the wall
spin and now i'm backwards on the
opposite side
and then take a step and then back to
the beginning again so i've continued
the movement round rather than reversing
so from this position i could stop
move round to this side continue the
figure eight
in a backwards motion step
and now i'm back to the opposite side
again we can just continue that
until it becomes fluid
in continuous again you can go both
directions with this
step this way and back
in my last video i'll talk about hand
transfers and this is something you can
introduce
whilst moving a good way to practice
this is actually timing
your step with your hand change
if for example i'm spinning in a
forwards figure eight here
i can change on this side to my left
hand
and i'm going to step with my left foot
there so it lands
together in this position do the same
again if i
step on my right side changes there
and the step forms at the same time as i
release
with the other hand if i change to the
other side here
i'm going to start to receive it with my
left hand and i'm going to take a step
back from my left leg
there so i fully release at that point
again if i take a step forward with my
left
and take a step forward and i'm now in
this position
so you could stop and pause between
these
changes so you become comfortable with
the movement
so if i'm spinning here i could change
the stop change
stop just get used to just
these different changes like i say to do
a change like this and
take it across your body or you could
change it like this there's so many
different changes again
i've done a video on this talking about
that and that's just something you can
experiment with these different
positions
and once you've done that you can try
the changes above your head
as well which is the same idea in this
position
i can change and step at the same time
once you're comfortable with these
aspects it's just a matter of practicing
experimenting
and linking everything together
if you've got any questions about what
i've covered please leave them in the
comments below
and please remember to like share and
subscribe as this helps the channel grow
in my next video i plan to look at staff
spinning and whether it has any martial
application
anyway until then take care and i'll see
you soon